[Music]
Bloomberg first reported and axios was
able to independently confirmed that
President Joe Biden in his new White
House budget is going to be proposing a
number of new taxes I am going to tell
you what they are and then we will
discuss whether they are likely to
become a reality axios writes the new
budget request to Congress set to be
released uh Thursday includes a 25
minimum tax on the richest
0.01 percent of Americans This is a
billionaire tax it would also increase
the top tax rate for those Americans
making four hundred thousand dollars a
year up to 39.6 percent from 37 percent
that was the rate prior to Trump's 27
tax bill 2017 tax bill it would go back
to that prior rate it would raise income
levies on corporations and billionaires
and it would set the corporate tax rate
at 28 still below the 35 percent rate
that was in place prior to Trump's 2017
tax law that is not the only thing that
Joe Biden plans to do he also plans an
increased Medicare tax remember when we
talk about social security and Medicare
sometimes people forget about the
Medicare piece uh what Joe Biden wants
to do
is increase the Medicare tax rate from
3.8 to 5 on income exceeding 400 000 per
year and it would apply to both salaries
as well as capital gains it would likely
increase tax revenues by over 117
billion dollars over 10 years so about
11.7 billion a year according to Prior
estimates from last month by the tax
policy Center so a couple different
things is Joe Biden sticking to his
promise not to increase taxes on people
making under four hundred thousand
dollars a year by all reasonable
assessments of these proposals the
answer is yes Joe Biden is not raising
taxes on anyone making under 400k
secondly is this likely to pass and the
answer is no I made this analysis When
Donald Trump would release his budgets
and it is the same analysis when Joe
Biden releases his budgets White House
budgets are political documents
political documents you have to get this
through the House of Representatives
currently controlled by Republicans in
order to make it a reality and so this
is a sort of wish list this is what you
could say Joe Biden would do
if he could wave a magic wand and to be
totally honest sometimes presidents
include things in White House budgets
that they wouldn't actually do if they
had full power to do it they included in
the budget as a signal a virtue signal
we have to admit knowing that it's not
going to pass which category are these
proposals under well we don't know
because we know that it is a White House
budget which is a political document so
it will be interesting to see however
are there negotiations to be had where
Republicans who control the house would
be willing to come to the table on some
of these proposals from Joe Biden in
exchange for what well we don't really
know in exchange for what we will be
watching it but so far these proposals
as unlikely as they are to become the
law
are keeping Joe Biden adhered to the
promise he made about Americans making
under four hundred thousand dollars per
year
the conspiracy theory that has been
widely debunked that being near someone
vaccinated against covid-19 can do
something to you has not gone away we
have another one of these very dangerous
Clips this is by the way
this is Lauren witsky Lauren witsky is
not some random person in the sense that
she was the Delaware Republican Party's
candidate for the senate in 2020.
thankfully she lost she is now claiming
she became sick after being around
someone
who had their covet vaccine and she
insists she's not crazy listen yeah and
the shedding is extremely real that's
how I caught whatever it was and you
can't tell me it wasn't a bio weapon
because I've had flus before I've had
you know tons of stuff wrong with me
before I've never experienced anything
like it it was like in your head it
stole your joy you couldn't like had
zero energy brain fog like it was almost
like I was poisoned it felt like
um you know and you know you can't tell
me covet itself wasn't a bio weapon but
I didn't catch covid I campaigned up and
down the state of Delaware she probably
had coveted 2020 during covid and didn't
catch anything I shook a thousand hands
didn't catch anything I was around a
family member who just got boosted
didn't tell me I've never been so sick
in my life and it wasn't like sickness
it was like I don't know how to explain
it but whatever is shedding off of them
made me sick and I've never quite been
the same I'm not as sharp as I used to
be I go back and I watch my interviews
from
2019-20 or 2020 and I'm like wow I was a
completely different person then she's
still very like I'm stupid no really it
did something to me and you can't tell
me it didn't because I know it did and
I'm not crazy right she's definitely not
crazy guys so listen the most likely
explanation is the simplest which is
Chicago she was around someone who had
coveted and she got covered the entire
vaccine shedding thing we've talked
about it before okay the idea of
shedding is someone gets vaccinated and
then they shed something off of their
body
um it's not supported by scientific
evidence it's not a real thing the covet
vaccines that are used in the U.S don't
contain any live virus so you can't shed
virus and the concept of shedding
vaccine just doesn't really make any
sense now if you're sick with covid
then you are shedding the virus when you
cough and so on and so forth and it
seems that that is probably what
happened here now one interesting thing
she says she hasn't been as sharp and
whatever as many of you remember I got
covered in early December I am
experiencing a long coveted symptom
which is my sense of smell is diminished
now I never lost my sense of smell or
taste when I had coveted
um it didn't go away but it was
diminished and what I realized now is
that it is still a diminished sense of
smell and honestly the the way that I
came to realize it is since having covid
I don't notice from just being in a room
with my baby daughter that she needs a
diaper change I used to just perceive it
from the smell people are understanding
I think what I'm saying I don't notice
anymore and my girlfriend will say does
she need a diaper change and I'll say oh
I don't know does she yeah it stinks in
here and I'll go I genuinely don't
notice that I can smell stuff but it is
diminished and I've read it can be 12 to
18 months thankfully I'm not
experiencing the brain fog that Lauren
whitsky uh seems to be struggling with
hey this you have to see
um a Fox News guest Stacy Washington
serious radio host says that one of the
reasons why we are seeing more
lawlessness in the United States is that
when you go to hotels now they don't
always have those Bibles in the
nightstand
that's the introduction let's listen to
what she said will they be I'll tell you
what will happen because
because they murder someone you don't
get in trouble here they're in hoodies
they're in masks will we be able to even
find out who did this if we were they
would be either charged as juveniles or
they'd be right back out on the streets
that's right and to Ainsley's Point
Stacy these businesses they these ones
that are open now are the ones that
survived covid they survived the
absolutely mind-boggling costs imposed
upon them by the government to make sure
that they complied with coveted
regulations the decrease in in customer
and customers because of the the
lockdown and the pandemic now they're
finally back on their feet they're
dealing with heightened taxes from this
Administration they're dealing with zero
foot traffic massive rent payments
because States like this are trying to
make up for the lack of Revenue and just
to get their business destroyed and
potentially their livelihood and one
five minute Fell Swoop so you see the
increase in lawlessness when we take God
out of everything so we're so far down
the Continuum on that and I'm talking
about the fact that if you stay in a
hotel anywhere you can't even find a
Bible in the nightstand anymore now
admittedly the Bible is on it's
expensive but it's just a thing
isn't that amazing so I have to admit I
am partially to blame for their not
being as many bibles in hotel hotel
nightstands anymore when I go into a
hotel
when I look in the nightstand if there
is a Bible there I put it out in the
hallway like your room service tray that
you're done with I take it I don't want
it in the room I admit that I do this
now sometimes I'll put it in the
recycling bin but I my instinct is that
the housekeeping staff probably takes it
out and puts it back in the nightstand I
don't know but my move is to take the
Bible and to put it in the hallway and
then it disappears I just don't want it
in the room with me now what where do
these Bibles come from this goes back to
actually 1899.
um there's a group called The Gideons
International and it was two traveling
sales people Samuel Hill and John
Nicholson and they started you know they
wanted to spread the word of God I guess
to as many people as possible they
thought hotel rooms are the place
because you've got people they're
traveling or whatever they might not
have access to a Bible so you stick a
Bible there and next thing you know
instead of going out and hiring a
prostitute or seeking drugs they'll say
I'm going to stay in and read the Bible
and so on and so forth and so this
started uh sometime between 1899 and
1908 and the Gideon started Distributing
these there are other groups that now do
it as well but Gideon's is the big one
so my move is blame me for it blame me
for the lawlessness I will if I find one
of the Bibles put it in the hallway it's
not part of the hotel room that I am
looking you know double vanity uh rain
shower uh shower head
um free Wi-Fi I'm right there with you a
couple free Fiji Waters maybe I love it
I don't need the Bible in the room with
me so I put it out in the hallway I
guess I'm responsible for the crime wave
in New York City
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show of course is a
community audience supported program the
best way to support the work we do every
day is to sign up at joinpakman.com and
get yourself a membership the
memberships are cheap they come with
great perks including the daily bonus
show and so many other different things
and also you can get a discount off of
the already
unbearably low costs of membership with
coupon codes like CPAC trash or 24
starts now or please no more Trump
please no more Trump let's hear from
some of the great people in our audience
we do this on our Friday show you can
call in through the David packman show
Discord which by the way you should join
anyway at davidpackman.com
Discord let's start today with Dan from
Ireland Dan from Maryland welcome to the
program what is on your mind today I'd
love to hear what uh what you've you've
been thinking about
David can you hear me yes
all right so you probably heard about it
now that my mayor was arrested for child
pornography your mayor I don't even know
what city you live in
College Park Maryland oh no I did not
hear about the College Park Maryland
he was arrested about 50 counts of child
pornography wow and I am absolutely
disgusted and disappointed because you
know I volunteered for him I campaigned
I voted and you feel pretty gross you
know after this happens but um my my
comment is more of you know she is an
openly gay man and I feel like this is
kind of feeds A Narrative of you know
the pedophile you know homosexual that
preys on children and I feel like with
what's going on with the anti-trans and
the drag queen shows and the more of the
laws that are happening I just feel like
it's a
I don't know it's a Log on the Fire if
that makes sense I totally understand
what you're saying and of course I mean
as as we know
um overwhelmingly the people arrested
for child porn uh are heterosexual and I
don't know of anyone who is saying we
have a problem with with heterosexuals
as a result of that and and one of these
things is what people create a narrative
and then they look only for examples
that confirm it but this is the first
time hearing of that story it sounds
like like he's been charged but not
found guilty at this point in time
that's always important to keep in mind
when we talk about these things but you
are without a doubt right that it will
be uh a way to throw a Log on the Fire
and that's the last thing we need right
now
yeah because also 12 Mayors so far this
year have also been arrested for similar
um I guess actions
um as well and it's just I don't know
it's just disappointing that you know
you live in a city and your mayor gets
arrested it's
um yeah so I just want to say that you
know I don't really have a question I
just wanted to put that out there but um
I also want to say that I'm in a um long
time listener and I'm glad that you are
keep going with the show and you do a
great job thank you very much Dan from
Maryland appreciate the call
you're welcome bye-bye all right there
it goes Dan let's go next to Kevin from
I hope I pronounced this correctly is it
Tukwila
it's Aquila
okay what state is that in
um it is in uh Washington State it's
like a 10 miles south from Seattle all
right well welcome to the show what's on
your mind today
well
um it's been a while since we last
talked and um I I will go to you for um
for some uh really important uh
questions if um if I don't know the
answer to then and I have one in
particular and I have a follow-up okay
uh so the question that I have is do you
feel that the um Biden's um green energy
plan through the inflation reduction Act
is
um it's like selling the cart before the
horse in what sense
like for for instance
um there's there's the um the concern
then that the that these green energy
projects might not
um there's a pro there's a process that
makes it so these green energy projects
are not enough
um
giving and given the permitting at the
PA at the pace they should be giving
giving their current um
occurrence system and that's what that's
why I'm in Center managed to introduce
permitting reform
um there's also the concern that perhaps
um like
um
there's a there's a there's a button
there's um probably not enough people
that can uh assume that can take on the
additional jobs those green energy oh I
see what you're saying no listen I'm not
concerned by that because sometimes in
order to create so you've got to
generate
if if the government doesn't first fund
some of these things the businesses
aren't going to start hiring and
training the people to do the work
because in general businesses aren't
going to say hey the government might
pass this so let's like hire and train a
whole bunch of people so I don't see
that as a bottleneck I don't see it as a
problem it might serve as a temporary
bottleneck but I think the right way to
do it is the government says hey we're
investing in these industries go grow
hire train people and there will be a
lag time but that's okay
and I see um but do you do you also feel
that that there might be
um
I don't know some
some additional
um ways to make the process a little bit
more a more more efficient assume
assuming that there's the dire need to
meet the uh the demand for addressing
climate change I'm sure there are and
whether it's government assisting in the
training so that people can be hired
more quickly to do some of the jobs for
these energy retrofits to move to New
renewable Technologies or I'm sure
there's a dozen ways to do it but uh
bottom line I think the right way is the
government says we're investing in this
stuff we're going to get right to it and
then uh figure figure out the rest
um all right Kevin thank you very much
for the call I do appreciate it let's go
next to Mike from Massachusetts Mike
from Massachusetts welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
hey David thanks for having me pleasure
um can you hear me all right yeah I can
hear you fine
awesome
um so my
um uh so obviously with everything going
on in the country lately like you know
especially especially on like you know
the front of like you know lgbtq rights
well you know Tennessee just bad gender
affirming care I think this for minors I
think Mississippi did recently too or
yes or something like that but
um anyway there's a lot and plenty of
other topics as well things just don't
look awesome at the moment
um so it's you know I was looking into
kind of how in the 2020 election and the
2022 election it seems that younger
voters particularly gen Z as they're
becoming a voting age now seem to be
changing the electorate the face of the
electorate
um and I came across this uh it's not a
report or maybe more of a study from The
Brookings Institute that they updated in
2020 that kind of project how
you know projects how you know with Baby
Boomers getting older and Jaden Z
getting older and just where the
Republican and Democratic Party stand on
certain social issues yeah how they
project that the electorate is going to
change and how various states are going
to change political leaning-wise right
over the next decade or so and I know
maybe this is a little naive to say but
the date even the most conservative
friendly model from that report is
exceptionally optimistic looking for the
Democrats
so it's kind of a two-part question one
do you believe that all these
demographic shifts and the continued
demographic shifts that a lot of people
seem to be portraying coming down the
line with Gen Z and the diversification
of Voters yeah do you think those are
genuine reasons to be optimistic going
forward for the next decade or so you
know I I do think so but at the same
time it's been 12 years at least of
people saying the demographic shifts in
Texas are going to make it a red State a
blue State the demographic shifts in
Georgia are going to make it a blue
State and it's like well Georgia did
vote for some Democratic senators that's
true but continued uh Republican
governors in Texas I mean yes the 2020
presidential was as close as it has been
in decades but it's definitely not a
blue state so on the one hand the the
predictions and the models seem sound
but I'm also aware that people have been
talking about this for 12 years and it
hasn't yet happened so so I I think it's
plausible that it will eventually happen
but I don't think it can it's a strategy
for Democrats anytime soon to just rely
on demographic changes
no I understand and um I think like yes
people have definitely been talking
about certain States particularly Texas
shifting from red to blue yeah for quite
a while now
um it seems like we are kind of finally
reaching a point like I guess I would
use the term inflection point yeah where
you know the oldest Baby Boomers and I
don't mean to be morbid about this but
the oldest baby boomers are only a year
or two away from the average life
expectancy in this country
um so that voting base is going to start
declining in gen Z which is by every
poll we can find overwhelmingly liberal
and Progressive no I agree I agree
it's just a matter of when and so in the
meantime we've got to do the best we can
to win elections the the the normal ways
which is
um making the right case on issues doing
the campaigning doing the work etc but
at some point I see it as hopefully a
bonus that is coming which is the
demographic advantages
oh absolutely they definitely need to
keep campaigning to win people over they
can't just rely on these changes but it
will make things easier and I guess the
second part of my question is if these
projections end up being even relatively
accurate I mean
what exactly would be
a possible approach for the Republican
party to remain politically relevant
they're already doing it it's just try
to steal the elections I mean that what
that's why they're already doing it
they're already losing on policy with
the electorate that we have and so the
approach is let's make it harder for
people to vote let's say we won even
when we didn't win let's look at purging
voter rolls they're doing all that stuff
they're just going to do even more of it
no 100 it's just I feel like that stuff
can only get you so far well we'll see I
mean let's let's see let's see how far
it gets them in 24 and then go from
there
fair enough fair enough
um
like I said it was just something that
like I came across and I was like is
this too good to be true or is this
genuine reason for optimism in the next
decade or so so you know I mean let's
just hope that the ship the shifts keep
happening and the Democrats keep not
completely shooting themselves in the
flood all right Mike from Massachusetts
very much well said always good to hear
from you let's go next to how about
Chris from Iowa Chris from Iowa what's
on your mind today
hi David can you hear me okay yes I can
wonderful so this is a question from a
uh expecting father myself to someone
who's currently a father uh in today's
you know what you call Golden Age of
ignorance
um some advice on how I mean I know that
your child is very young but how to uh
raise a child with a lot of really poor
influences out there when it comes to
ignorance
um I currently live in Iowa and right
now our state has gotten more and more
down that road of ignorance and uh it's
very concerning and I know you live in a
much more you know much more Progressive
area but uh what advice would you have
to kind of keep those you know ignorant
influences away while being aware that
they still exist and not being
completely shielding from them so
there's a couple different things here
first of all there are some things where
if your child is eventually going to
have access to Media or be around other
people be in public go to Public School
Etc there there are certain things that
you're that are realistically not going
to be uh you're not going to be able to
prevent them from seeing and being to
some degree influenced by whether you're
in a red state or a blue State because
of media and what is in media so first
of all you've got to be realistic so
unless you're going completely off the
grid in the middle of nowhere
um that you can't just kind of protect
forever I don't think that all being
said
um and this is a really tough thing to
even really talk about but
if it comes down to what's best for your
family I would understand people looking
and saying hey you know Mississippi
Arkansas Alabama
The Dakotas for picking a few States and
saying look at the infrastructure look
at education look at life expectancy
look at the quality of the Health Care
System look at crime look at all these
different things and look at the
countries that are equivalent when it
comes to those metrics to those States
and then you look at States like
Connecticut and New York and
Massachusetts and Vermont and and to
some degree you know Maryland and
Delaware and you say wow the metrics in
those countries are similar to if you
were to live in Norway or Sweden or a
lot of the places we think are great at
a certain point there's there's the
thought of am I living in the right
state for what I think is best for my
family and obviously I'm not
um understating what it means to move to
a different part of the country job
housing family all these different
things I'm not understating it in any
way
but I think it is a an important thing
just to ask oneself am I in the right
place for raising kids the way I want to
raise them and you know it's it's a it's
a difficult question to answer in in
some cases but I think it's an important
one to at least ask
yeah no I I really appreciate that you
know just to follow up briefly on that
you know I've always heard you know the
you know you hear The Grass Is Always
Greener somewhere else but yeah
sometimes you got to mow your lawn right
and uh I you know I I truly think that
Iowa 15 years ago was a purple state if
not Progressive yeah and I do want I do
feel like a civic duty to stay here and
to at least you know do what I can to
vote the people who need to be in power
into power right at least you know do do
as much as I can 100 percent
I do love this area but I am quite
concerned about the direction it has
gone in and um you know with a child
coming on the way in the summer you know
that just exacerbates all the concerns
that I have here yeah and I've talked to
people about this who say hey you know
what I would really like is to stay
where I am and Achieve positive change
so it's a better place for my kid
beautiful I think that's fantastic in
some places what that change would be is
so lopsided and so overwhelming and your
kids three four five they're starting to
enter the world in a certain way I don't
blame anyone for saying I'm bailing out
for the good of my family I not everyone
can afford to do it and there's all
these ifs ands and buts but I wouldn't
blame people for doing it if that's what
they decide is best for them
wonderful well thank you so much for
your uh for taking the time appreciate
it all right Chris from Iowa let's take
a very quick break we're not done with
phone calls if you're holding on to talk
to me just hang on because we're going
right back to Discord in a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's talk
to some more people it's Friday after
all we take calls via Discord
davidpackman.com
slash Discord why don't we go next later
we'll see where we go but let's go next
to Joseph from Tucson Arizona uh the
place in Arizona where I've spent the
most time by far Joseph welcome to the
program what's going on
all right thank you David uh can you
hear me yes I can
so just hypothetically speaking yes if
Trump were to get indicted sometime this
year okay and Trump supporters were to
violently
um riot in response yes would that hurt
Republicans in 2024
it's an interesting question
um I think the answer depends on who's
the nominee right if Trump is indicted
and his supporters Riot and Trump
doesn't denounce it and he is the
nominee I think that that hurts Trump if
Trump gets indicted and his supporters
Riot and Trump either drops out or loses
the nomination
I think that whoever is the eventual
nominee probably isn't affected
negatively by these hypothetical Trump
riots you're talking about so I think it
depends on who is the nominee
interesting yeah I was kind of thinking
along similar lines um where it
definitely would hurt Trump um kind of
um in either way kind of damned if he
does then if he doesn't kind of thing
um and deservedly so I'd probably say
what do you mean by that damned if he
does you're saying whether or not he
denounces or what do you mean
I think either way he definitely would
face a lot of backlash
um obviously from the left but I think
in a lot of pockets of the right
um if a combination of a trump
indictment and violent riots were to
occur I think a lot of the smaller
pockets of the right who um are more
quiet about their disdain for Trump
would be a lot louder but I think uh
would gain a lot more support
um because of such
um uh a violent occurrence that very
well may be that very well may be let's
hope there is no such violence uh that
would be the best thing
yeah
um that would that would obviously be
the best um the best course of action
um and as a kind of unrelated uh side
question sure I was wondering if you had
any uh book recommendations related to
U.S foreign policy
uh I really don't I tend not to read uh
sort of like new foreign policy type
books I have so many other things on my
on my pile including science and
narrative nonfiction and history and
different things I I just don't I I'm
not really reading in that genre right
now so I don't have any recommendations
okay that's fine all right thank you for
taking my call all right Joseph from
Tucson great to hear from you let's go
next to Jack from Pennsylvania Jack from
Pennsylvania welcome what's on your mind
today
hello David first time caller here
um here's a quick hypothetical question
for you
um well I think I first want to start
off with like I said like a scenario
here
um well first actually do you think it's
possible
um if either two parties grow more
divided between like democrats for
example the progressive and the moderate
camp and the Republicans the modern the
Maca Camp do you think it's possible to
see like something that go like what
happens in a wig party in the 1800s
where like the entire party collapses
for like the um it like splits up into
two other parties I do think it is
possible but the very entrenched system
we have for the major parties including
uh financing and commission on
presidential debates and all of these
other status quo entrenchments that we
have would make it much more difficult
to see what happened to the Whig party
it's possible but I don't see it as
likely
on that question if it does happen to
one of the other parties let's say that
they're like magas and they say like the
Republican party like collapses do you
think it'll be smart for it to progress
for the progressive uh caucus in the
Democratic Party
hello
all right we lost Jack Jack was getting
to some follow-up but we lost him with a
very strange digital noise right at that
moment let's go next to Edward from
Colorado Edward from Colorado welcome to
the program uh what's on your mind today
hi there David can you hear me okay yes
I can
okay so I had a question
a patrol
I could do some presidential candidates
you're you're cutting in and out Edward
you said you had a question about
presidential candidates
about a potential Gavin Newsom candidacy
oh okay go ahead
so I guess with him
do you feel like uh
like the severity of California's covet
lockdowns would kind of thing
oh my God Edward you're cutting in and
out with the severity of the lockdowns
do what
do you think it would be a substantive
enough criticism that it would hurt him
substantially electorally no I don't
all right Edward the connection is
atrocious so I'm going to let you go
it's just it's very very very very very
bad let's go next to Bert from New
Jersey Bert from New Jersey welcome
please save us let's hope your
connection is better than the last two
have been
hey David how's my connection it's
beautiful so far
awesome awesome thanks for uh picking on
me pleasure
um here's my question uh when people
criticize Biden yes uh from the from the
right typically right
first thing they talk about is inflation
this is Biden's economy Biden's
inflation bite inflation right
um the very nature of how inflation
occurs as you increase the money supply
right
so Trump in four years increased the
money supply more than any U.S president
in the history of our country in a
four-year span right
so my my question is
um why don't people call that out where
okay your your guest inflation well how
are you for Trump then that conversation
well increasing the money supply
depending on how it's done and for what
purposes can have an inflationary effect
it is not a guarantee that it does so I
think at least we on the left want to be
a little more uh precise with with that
and tactical in terms of when when we
when we bring it up but you're right
that at least as far as the right is
concerned that is true and listen you
this is not new ground in the sense that
I've said before
when Republicans say that Biden's covet
stimulus caused inflation Trump did two
of the stimuluses or stimuli as well as
PPP which became a fraudulent slush fund
so the I think the the way I would
approach it is aside from debating the
money supply issue
if you blame Biden you have to blame
Trump at least two times more because he
did two of the coveted stimulus packages
and of course they don't because they
don't actually care or no it's just
about what can I get away with saying
and who can I criticize who's on the
left
right and maybe money supply is not the
right word what I'm really getting at is
deficits right it's Trump had an eight
trillion dollar budget deficit in four
years right that gets funded not through
borrowing money not through raising
taxes through just for any money supply
right that alone has a huge catastrophic
effect on inflation it's no coincidence
it started when Trump is leaving yeah I
I think that the you know their modern
monetary theorists disagree with that
premise and are working hard to explain
to us that that's not actually the case
let where I will leave it is you're
absolutely right in assessing the
conventional wisdom around a lot of
these issues and Republicans are
complete Hypocrites and they're ignoring
of it as it pertains to Trump 100 right
on that
right right so you said you can't be a
New York Giants and a Philadelphia
Eagles fan at the same time it's like I
guess not I guess not that sounds tough
yeah
all right Bert thank you for the call I
appreciate it thank you David all right
there is Bert from Jersey great to hear
from you uh why don't we go next to a
treaties from Boston a treaties from
Boston welcome what's going on
hey David so I had a question about
Florida okay
okay so um it's no secret I mean the
census won by the highest uh
gubernatorial margin in Florida history
I think it was 1.5 million votes and in
his four years uh of
um in elected office he's especially in
the last couple years been basically
drunk with power you know what they
don't say gay Bill uh the Jerry bring a
whole list of things and just recently
you talked about how he wanted to
um or at least his State Senate wanted
to ban the Democratic Party from Florida
how
um
um he wanted to ban journalists from
criticizing him in fact I was just
listening to your colleague fair and
cousins last night saying that he who
lives in Florida is considering moving
because of this
um I basically wanted to ask the broad
question uh is Florida Beyond saving at
this point or do you think the pendulum
is going to swing back at some point no
I wouldn't say Florida is beyond saving
because what you have to remember is
that the number of Democrats in Florida
is insanely high as a result of the fact
that Florida's population is so uh large
and although that margin certainly was
was a record record for for the
Governor's race
um I would not in any way think about
abandoning Florida I think Florida is a
project where it has certainly started
to lean more red than it was you know in
the bush era for example
um but that I would I would be I think
it would be a disastrous idea for
Democrats to abandon it I think it's a
great opportunity opportunity the
pendulum does often swing back and uh I
mean listen if DeSantis became president
it could create a vacuum in Florida that
could actually be really good for
Democrats I think it would be a very bad
idea to say we're not we're not thinking
about Florida anymore
yeah I'm kind of in the same uh boat as
you I just I hear a lot of talk of it's
time to let Florida go no not in the
same way like and then yeah no I agree
with you I mean it has from what I
understand the fourth highest LGBT
population uh it's a state that Obama
won twice it has very high personal uh
person of color uh population so yeah I
agree with you that it's not Beyond
saving I just think there's there's
definitely a lot of panic among the left
yeah what to do Florida let's not panic
and let's keep working because I think
it's a it would be a huge mistake to
give it up uh A Treatise from Boston
great to hear from you today I do
appreciate it very much let's see if we
can speak to Dariel from Texas is that
the right way to say it Dariel
uh like hi David uh it's my first time
going on a show I've been watching a
show for a while kind of nervous but
I'm doing great so far what's on your
mind
okay so I just saw this clip from MSNBC
where like Monday Jones basically talked
about how democrats should be happy that
Trump has like a Stranglehold over the
GOP and that Trump has a real shot of
like winning or like winning the by The
Joker nomination yeah and like my
question to you would be like should
Democrats like like luxury Democrats
have that attitude of like oh oh we
should we should want Trump to beat a
GOP nominee because he'd be easier to be
in the general I just talked about this
with Adam Schiff earlier this week Adam
I I lean more I'm more sympathetic to
what you're saying because I think Trump
would be easier to beat
and also would be less disastrous if he
were president because DeSantis would
get more done but I still see Trump as
having a really good shot of winning in
24. uh Adam Schiff disagreed with me I I
think it it's really a matter of opinion
I don't think there's like an
objectively right answer on this issue
because we're estimating we're making a
prediction as to what Trump would do if
he were president four more years from
age 78 to 82 or whatever whatever it
would be right we're being forced to say
what would happen and based on what we
think would happen what's better so it's
a matter of opinion but I am sympathetic
to the idea that it is better for
Democrats to run against Trump I could
be wrong we're not going to know uh at
minimum we're not going to know until it
happens and it may not happen
oh gosh you're okay yes I just thought
it was interesting to mention because I
remember during 2016 like the Hillary
campaign I believe they tried like doing
like the Pied Piper strategy where they
where like like they wanted to uh push
Trump to be the nominee with the
expectation that Trump is easier to be
but we all saw it backfires it backfired
oh you're right and that's something
I've brought up yeah
yeah so yeah I just I'm just worried
that that Democrats like like they could
get complacent you know and potentially
bought it again like 2016. well that's
the biggest and most important thing
which is no matter who is the eventual
Republican nominee Democrats can always
find a way to screw it up and that's
what should really scare us
uh yes uh that's my question I just
thought it was interesting to bring up
all right thank you for for the call
thank you Dario from Texas great to hear
from you let's go to a break that does
it for calls today I will take calls
again and I hope to be able to speak to
you next time
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
let's go to the Friday Feed Bag someone
wrote to me and said David instead of
feedback Friday or Friday feedback you
should call it the Feed Bag like a horse
that eats out of a bag I don't know
listen folks I'm gonna go over some
messages that I received from people uh
significant reaction to the anti-trans
explosion from CPAC over the weekend one
message I received very much
representative of others Kyle said what
about all the rights the drag and trans
Community
is trying to take from all other people
so
I don't know what the hell Kyle's
talking about and I've heard this before
that the people's rights are being taken
by the the drag and trans Community
since Dragon Trends are two different
things let's maybe see if we can think
that through I can't even think of any
bad arguments that the drag Community is
taking anybody's rights I know the right
might say well
they're taking away parents rights not
to be around drag queens they're really
not and when you look at the details of
all of these drag time story hours and
whatever
parents are bringing their kids to them
so I don't understand how anybody's
losing a right there if anything parents
are continuing to have the right to say
here's what I want to show my kid or
here's what I don't want to show my kid
now as far as the trans Community I
think or the argument they love to make
is if I quote have to call someone by a
certain pronoun
then I've lost my right of Free Speech
but of course that's not really the case
what we're talking about here is decorum
there are situations where States might
have a law for example with regard to
being able to change your driver's
license or at work changing your
employee file if you've transitioned but
these things don't really have anything
to do with rights and it's sort of like
if you're just out in the world
and you don't want to use someone's
preferred pronouns it's not a question
of Rights it's just a question of
decorum and politeness the same way that
you could choose to use racist words
around people it's not a matter of
Rights it's a matter of how are you
going to treat others so as usual they
talk about Free Speech when it's not a
free speech issue they talk about rights
when it's not a rights issue okay a lot
of people don't like my analyzes and
coverage of trump speeches and rallies
Laura wrote to me and said you're
horrible it's the wrong you're
required it's the wrong you're you're
horrible making from of trump I assume I
assume Laura means making fun of trump
you're horrible my horrible making from
of trump the best ever get a life and
find another job you aren't funny fact
worthless she adds
my favorite thing I have to I know that
this some people don't like this my
favorite thing
is when people hate
that this is my job
and it's a great job to have with tons
of great benefits and perks and the
ability to communicate with great people
every day and build a community so you
know what Laura I think I'm gonna keep
my job and if you don't like my thoughts
about Trump's speeches you don't have to
watch Cooper left a comment you're free
again it's the wrong your guys you're
free y o u r free
to do whatever you want as long as
you're prepared wrong you're to suffer
the consequences so keep on doing drag
shows for kids and you'll eventually get
what's coming to you
is this a threat of violence against the
drag performers because who's doing the
drag shows the drag performers and and
what on Earth could possibly be coming
to them they're not doing anything wrong
everybody's fine I was thinking the
other day talking with a friend of mine
you know
when my daughter is at whatever age she
might find
any of this entertaining would there be
anything damaging if she saw a drag
performer and I really couldn't think of
anything he just said what how would
that even rank how would that be
anything to even be remotely concerned
about so I don't know what the
consequences are going to be and I don't
even know what Cooper says the
consequences are to the people seeing
the drag shows it's all wild
abortion still an issue for many in our
audience David wrote In left a comment
and said what young people don't
understand is you will reach out to God
on your deathbed how will you explain
your stance on abortion or the abortions
you had you will reach for hope no
matter what in the end
David
I'm ready to make a promise to you today
I am never never
going to feel the need to explain to
anyone
the abortions I've had
because I'm not going to be having any
but this is a really common guilt thing
this is a big
I would say this is a really Christian
thing now many Christians would say
that's not that's not the spirit of
Christianity what I mean is a lot of
Evangelical Christians will fear-monger
in this way
which is when the time comes for your
ultimate judgment here on Earth
you're going to repent
for what you did if you chose to have an
abortion
um these folks need to move on from
something to something other than fear
except the fear works really well that's
why they keep at it
us many people not liking my uh Bill
Maher criticisms lately
Sammy wrote in and said bro
bro you could do better than attacking
Bill Maher if you don't see wokeness as
a problem you're not looking hard enough
well remember even Bill Maher couldn't
Define wokeness he was given the
opportunity by Jake Tapper on CNN what
do you mean by woke and he said
something about Abraham Lincoln okay uh
if they want to actually explain what
they mean by woke then I'm glad to
engage with it in that way but
um that seeing wokeness is a problem I
don't even know what you mean by woke
and most of them don't even know what
they mean that's been something we've
looked at a number of times David says
the populace left is no better than the
populist right
one tends to lead to actual communism
and the other tends to lead to actual
fascism unfortunately the more Centrist
positions require a lot more work to
maintain the leaders of either side have
to work harder to craft something
meaningful that the voters will respond
to consistently and the voters
themselves must work harder to stay
accurately informed about the issues but
that in essence is also the key to a
functioning democracy best of luck to us
but the big picture going forward isn't
very promising listen I
I don't know about populist left leads
to actual communism I'm not sure about
that but what I will tell you is I have
called out populist rhetoric on the left
and right for a very long time what's my
main gripe with populism it's that
populism is not a policy platform or a
set of policy ideas populism is a
rhetoric and as a rhetoric it can be
used to bamboozle people
into all sorts of bad policy the example
I've used before is you know both Bernie
and Tucker will use populist sounding
rhetoric about the abandoned middle
class sounds very similar
Tucker's proposal though
is we need to do something about black
lives matter who will take your house
and brown immigrants who will take your
job right that Tucker uses the rhetoric
to suggest those as policies and so I've
said for a long time we've got to be
really careful about populist rhetoric
populism it's not really a set of policy
ideas but it is a rhetoric and it can be
used in a lot of horrible ways Joseph
left a comment on Facebook about the
Loyalty pledge that Donald Trump is
being asked to sign Joseph says Trump
could very well sign the pledge he would
want to be on the debate he wants the
attention if he doesn't end up the
Republican candidate I think he would
claim the process was rigged in some way
I think he's determined to be on the
ballot whether is the Republican
candidate or as an independent if he
becomes an independent candidate on the
ballot and he comes in third I think
everyone would finally turn against him
even the Maga freaks will turn their
backs on him if that happens maybe Trump
will finally fade away yeah I I I mean
listen guys he's 76 he'll be 78-ish at
the time of the election I think that if
Trump doesn't win the nomination uh and
or doesn't find a way to win the
presidential election his political
career is over and I know you know a lot
of people insist oh Bernie should run
again or whatever Bernie's done with
running for president I would bet money
on that
um and uh otherwise I think Joseph is
absolutely right Trump will do what he
needs to do to get on the stage and then
that is that bill posted to the
subreddit and says I don't know if this
is a tough touchy touchy subject in here
or not but what in the heck is David
doing with his mustache he's my favorite
media personality but this is getting
out of control he looks like a Teenage
Dirtbag it's very off-putting is he
trolling somebody I don't understand
it's awful he's a very handsome guy when
he's clean shaven but it's clear
whatever he's doing with his facial hair
is 100 deliberate so I utterly perplexed
by his choice I'm sorry David but it's
one of the worst mustaches I've ever
seen it looks terrible I love this and I
also love only two-thirds of the V of
the audience agrees with this take
one-third does not folks this is
satirical facial hair satirical okay
I've even got a mullet going it's just a
joke it's satire now I've got the goatee
I'm getting a haircut in a couple days
we're gonna reboot everything just relax
I'm glad it provides entertainment but
it's really not worth getting so worked
up about but and absolutely Gene if if
the message what I'm wondering is is
this message satire as well
it's uh it's awful one of the worst
mustaches I've ever seen I love it all
right and then window Piper via Reddit
says David
don't feed the drills with recurring
segments about stupid YouTube comments
or emails it seems to me that David is
forgetting a cardinal rule of
interacting online don't feed the trolls
don't let them know that their idiotic
waffle bothers you don't engage at all
when you read out the ridiculous
nonsense and complain about the grammar
you're signaling they can reach you and
it affects you enough to feature in the
show don't over explain you don't need
to preempt criticisms like you just want
war with Russia or you're a communist
adapting your Viewpoint points to
anticipate the BS only encourages more
with affection from a long time viewer
ignore the wing nuts don't give them any
time or consideration end of rant yeah I
mean listen I don't agree with this a
hundred percent I agree with it 90
that's why when we do the Friday
feedback segment or whatever
um it's just we feature a small sample
of the unhinged attacks and mostly try
to focus on productive discussions I do
think that if we pretend that they don't
exist
we fall into an echo chamber
um and I don't think that that's good
so I think they should be featured
in a limited manner
handled appropriately
uh uh and in that sense
I think it's productive and a healthy
thing rather than creating yet another
Echo chamber all right send in your
thoughts info davidpackman.com leave a
YouTube comment post a tweet whatever
might be featured here make sure that
you're signed up to the YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show and
remember to sign up for a membership at
joinpakman.com it's the number one
funding source for the David packman
Show
joinpakman.com coupon code
please no more Trump that's the code
please no more Trump I'll see you on the
bonus show